we're out here in the middle of the
Arizona desert during one of the worst
Mega droughts of the past 1200 years
to pump unlimited amounts of groundwater
to irrigate Farm fields in the desert
and grow one of the most water intensive
crops there is Alfalfa so what is this
company doing with all of this Alfalfa
well they're putting it on trucks and
they put it on trains and they put it on
ships and they send it back to the
Middle East so why are they growing
these crops out here in Arizona instead
of back home well it's illegal to grow a
crop like Alfalfa in Saudi Arabia
because it uses too much water the
Attorney General of Arizona says this is
an outrage she says this is scandalous
and she's trying to get these leases
which are on state-owned land canceled
so this will stop happening she says
that these four known companies should
not be allowed to operate here in
Arizona especially now that water is a
depression